Ça fait du bien tous ces arbres,
on est obligé de sortir la tête haute
et de lever les yeux au ciel.
Il y a des chênes,
des hêtres,
des frênes,
quelques érables et surtout beaucoup
de châtaigniers dans cette forêt.
Aïe !
Ça pique ! Pas les châtaignes,
c'est un peu trop tôt. Les orties !
Elles portent bien
leur nom, ça chauffe.
Orties.
"Urtica" en latin, vient de "Uro"
qui signifie "brûler".
Comment des feuilles peuvent-elles
provoquer une telle réaction ?
Ça donne vraiment envie de gratter, mais pas trop quand même.
Tout se passe en surface. Les feuilles des orties sont recouvertes de poils urticants
Allez, on va aller
voir ça de plus près.
ELa petite caméra a photographié
de très très près une ortie.
Regardez, on voit très bien les poils
qui se dressent à la surface de la feuille.
Comme vous pouvez le constater,
ce ne sont pas vraiment des poils mais des petits réservoirs. Ils ressemblent à des ampoules, vous savez :
celles qui contiennent un médicament et libèrent leurs contenus de la même manière.
La pointe
est en silice.
Le matériau de base avec lequel
on fait du verre.
C'est elle qui s'enfonce
dans nos tissus.
Comme elle est très fragile,
elle se brise instantanément
comme l'extrémité
d'une ampoule
et déverse son contenu
dans nos tissus.
Et là, ça pique.
Qu'est ce qu'il y a
là-dedans ?
Je vous préviens, je le fais qu'une fois.
De l'histamine, responsables de
l'inflammation et des démangeaisons.
De l'acide formique, le poison produit
par les fourmis et les abeilles.
De la sérotonine, également
responsable de l'inflammation.
Et de l'acétylcholine,
une substance impliquée
dans les chocs allergiques.
Mais pas de panique,
l'ortie n'en produit qu'en toute petite quantité,
juste histoire de marquer les esprits.
De nous éloigné d'elle et de repousser les herbivores.
Pas de quoi s'alarmer donc et piétiner
toutes les orties que nous rencontrons sur notre passage. D'autant que cette plante peut être très utile,
on peut en faire un engrais et un pesticide naturel. On peut aussi la consommer sous forme de soupes.
Si si !
Bon, là il va m'en manquer un peu,
je retourne en cueillir en forêt.
Je vais être très bien ici.
Au passage, je vous invite à porter des gants car il y avait également des poils urticants au niveau de la tige.
Allez, c'est parti.
Alors je sais, ce n'est pas très appétissant et pourtant,
on peut aussi consommer les feuilles d'ortie
quand elles sont fraîches.
Pour cela, il faut choisir une feuille
toute jeune, comme celle ci.
Et ça peut même
se faire à mains nues.
L'idée, c'est d'attraper la feuille
par le dessous
car sur les jeunes pousses,
il y a moins de poils urticants
dessous que dessus.
On l'a détache
puis on l'a replie sur elle-même.
On écrase bien pour briser toutes les
petites ampoules et les vider de leur liquide.
On replie la feuille
sur elle-même
et on pince,
une fois supplémentaire
en appuyant bien, y compris aux extrémités.
Voilà. Et maintenant,
on peut déguster.
Ça ne pique absolument pas !
Allez, je m'y remets.
Là je dois avoir
pas loin d'un kilogramme.
Pour 4 personnes il faut compter 700 grammes d'orties. Cous commencez par les laisser au soleil ou à l'air libre,
histoire que les poils urticants se dessèchent, pour que les feuilles ne présentent plus aucun danger.
Passé ce délai, eh bien vous voyez, vous pouvez
saisir les tiges et détacher les feuilles.
Ça ne pique plus du tout.
Vous lavez les feuilles à l'eau claire.
Puis vous faites fondre une noix de beurre dans une casserole,
vous pouvez éventuellement
rajouter un oignon.
Vous y déposez les feuilles d'ortie et vous les faites suer,
vous leur faites perdre un maximum d'humidité.
Puis vous ajoutez un litre d'eau et vous laissez mijoter.
Au bout d'un quart d'heure / une demi-heure,
quand les feuilles commencent à se déliter,
un coup de mixeur,
de la crème fraîche
et c'est prêt !
Vous savez quoi, je vais en faire pousser un peu dans mon jardin,
pas que pour la cuisine,
une vingtaine d'espèces de papillons
pond exclusivement sur les orties et en plus, elles hébergent certains parasites.
Les pucerons notamment, qui préféreront s'y installer plutôt que sur mes pommiers.
On goûte ?
C'est pas mauvais, mais je vais rajoute
un peu de poivre. Ça manque de piquant !
Allez, à très bientôt pour une nouvelle capsule de déconfiné "lungo" !
Vous pouvez retrouver la recette de la soupe aux orties
à la page 83 de mon livre "Tu l'as dit Jamy !",
illustré par Leslie Plée
aux éditions Stock.